e
[Musica]
signore e signori
innanzitutto chiedo venia perché nel
ripetere il talk and view esattamente
immaginati così come un po baa3 non può
frida kahlo
spero che vi faccia piacere insomma
io so che vi siete chiesti ma questa c'è
o ci fa
perché stavo pazientando stavo
aspettando
tempo pazienza
due qualità non proprio ben accette
insomma nei tempi moderni tra parentesi
non vi preoccupate se lo chiedono tutti
se ci sono o ci faccio però converrete
con me che per respirare con
consapevolezza
ci vuole del tempo e della pazienza
allora io vi faccio una domanda
la prima è facile la seconda un pochino
più difficile respirare è una cosa
naturale
sì o no
secondo chi no
secondo nessuno ok
adesso mi raccomando i vostri neuroni
devono essere molto ben connessi perché
questa è la seconda domanda difficile
che sa cosa vuol dire respirare questo è
difficile la m cosa vuol dire respirare
mentre voi ci pensate io vi chiedo di
respirare forte ora le chiedo di restare
forte e non dovete fare come al
catechismo o alla messa che quando il
prete vi dice ditte il padre nostro
padre nostro
pure a yoga lo respirate voi invece
la fiatella di cipolla cioè non
interessa
quindi cosa vuol dire respirare c'è
qualche volontario non fate come al
catechismo non mi fate essere la maestra
antipatica
vivere
bravo
bravo e anche nella risposta hai letto
il mio copione da verità si vuol dire
sentirsi vivere o vivi
all'interno di questa cosa no della
respirazione
io ci metto si respira per vivere o per
sopravvivere me lo immagino proprio come
un diagramma bene io mi sono resa conto
adesso 37 anni a 36 che io
[Musica]
vivevo per sopravvivere non vivevo per
vivere triste direte voi insomma però me
ne era accorta un po troppo tardi
perché avevo il preconcetto di dire io
valgo perché appaio quindi valgo perché
lavoro 16 ore su 24
valgo perché gli altri vogliono che io
sia così
e quindi sopravvivevo e non vivevo
questa è la mia opera che si chiama
fettina di culo che diciamo
equivale a tutte le volte che quando i
clienti mi chiamavano il dice vuoi pure
una fettina di culo by the way labbra in
vendita se vi interessa vi do il numero
poi nel al di là del teatro quindi io in
tutto ciò non avevo capito che per
respirare con consapevolezza per vivere
mi mancava un capitale che male il
capitale dei soldi no perché qui alla
fine tutti è che siamo rincorriamo non
so che cosa perché te lo fanno credere
no che devi correre per guadagnare mi
mancava il capitale umano
[Musica]
onestamente adesso sono molto ricca di
capitale umano la mia banca di capitale
umano è davvero insomma rigogliosa
questi sono degli umani che ha raccolto
un po come faceva il protagonista di un
libro che raccoglieva pezzi di
di cose li metterà mente le bustine io
raccolgo umani perché gli umani mimì
fanno bene mi fanno respirare mi aprono
ai polmoni
quando i miei due voli sono troppo
stretti io mi ricordo tutti gli umani o
con fotografato e che ho ripreso e
questo invito anche a voi di guardarvi
più intorno di guardarmi in faccia per
adesso ci sono solo gli occhi perché
abbiamo quasi tutti ancora la mascherina
però vi prego di farlo
insomma fondamentalmente io
cosa sono perché sono qua io sono una
creativa è ovviamente ancora manco i
miei genitori hanno capito quindi cosa
vuol dire creativa si ho capito ma
quindi come guadagno me li fa i soldi
come lo paga un mutuo
io produco idee e le vendono stati
sembra incredibile che se me l'avessero
detto da piccola che tra l'altro volevo
fare l'inventrice di spremiagrumi poi
purtroppo scoprì che c'era già
esistevano già però ecco io sono una
creativa una tattica che per un certo
punto sia sentita in apnea in apnea
perché io creavo per gli altri per le
aziende
insomma una creativa a creare per le
aziende e non solo per per sé
i polmoni ti si chiudono allora
cominciai da un anno questo ho
cominciato questo percorso di
trasformazione e cominciò da fare qua a
fare cose per me voi fate cose per voi
avete degli hobby
perché molto importante
il mio lavoro è vendere prodotti
digitali alle aziende quindi io convinta
di avere un'idea geniale andai da delle
aziende di bellezza e dire l'idea
geniale
adesso siamo nel momento in cui si
ribadisce l'esigenza di un olio lingua
di un genere e fluido quindi siamo ci
vogliamo tutti bene quindi perché non
fare dei contenuti con il signore che ne
so di 75 anni che si trucca non sono
l'esperimento sociale mettiamo dei
trucchi davanti a un signore di 75 anni
è no luciano si può fare ma va a nava
l'ho fatto lo stesso lui e mio papà
l'uni papa e lui si è
prestato a questa follia mio passi
presto tantissime follia e la fine ho
chiamato questo progetto rita award
nessuno me l'ha mai comprato on line
le proposte diverto molto moltissimo si
è sentito libero libero e alla fine
guarda un po sono stata scelta per
esporre queste opere a torino
altra idea geniale altro esempio di
creatività per me che mi ha liberato i
polmoni
parlo con delle azioni di oggetti
gioielli dico un'idea geniale questo
mondo di follower di vanità di tra un po
di abbrutimento perché alla fine siamo
sempre col capo chino sui social
benissimo voi che fate i gioielli
denunciamo questa cosa
il paradosso la cattività si basa anche
sul paradosso e no lucia ma vogliamo la
modella così così su instagram ha ormai
compra il gioiello o no o sbaglio
ho fatto da sola ho fatto da sola ho
creato chiamato questo progetto
fotografato da mauro serra vanity fair
mi sono ispirata ad orwell e guarda caso
è stato scelto
per essere esposto alla design week
la libertà la libertà di fare cose per
te quindi affronta di tutto per tutto
ciò ho creato un'altra opera ovviamente
dalle allusioni insomma voi sapete quali
fallo e basta quindi vi auguro anche
diciamo diamo anche voi di fare le cose
e basta farle per voi
bello tutto lucia ho capito ma chi sei
cosa fai perché sei qua come il fatto
come imparato a respirare per vivere e
non per sopravvivere ma cile un certo
punto ho avuto tutto cambiato casa
cambiato amici che sta proprio è stata
una cosa abbastanza naturale no sono
cambiata io ho capito che non volevo più
sopravvivere le persone tifo così tipo
via via tutte via io tifo
perché mi buttavano giù e buttavano giù
quindi fondamentalmente ho cominciato ad
accogliere persone molto positive tante
buddiste non so se sia un caso no ma
niente un caso ho cominciato a lasciar
andare anche persone che amavo
credo che sapete tutto e tutti che le
scelte giuste sono anche quelle molto
dolorose facile scelte giuste e belle
ragazze siamo anche in un mondo insomma
vero no quindi lasciare andare
ho cominciato a ballare liberamente un
certo punto mi sono sentita posseduta
dal dio della danza danza cominciato a
trovarmi in casa così che ballavo come
lo so una menade libera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
dove
detto questo ho cominciato anche a
pensare a tutto quello che vedevo in tv
e nei social e nei giornali e mi
dicevano devi sognare in grande perché
se non so niente di non diventare un
amministratore delegato non sei nessuno
dicevo ma io non credo di avere nelle
carte nelle le capacità né di volere io
voglio una barchetta sul mar egeo dove
andare a pescare pesche e dove insegnare
che pesca e pesca sono due cose diverse
invece no tutti no perché tu devi
diventare ragazzi e che valiamo solo se
siamo al top dell'azienda quindi
comincia a pensare a tutte queste cose
ho cominciato a
soffrire perché dovevo lasciare tutto
quello che credevo prima le
sovrastrutture che mi ero messa perché
gli altri mi dicevano non vali niente se
tu non lavora 24 ore al giorno sono
diventi importante c'è ma che cosa sei e
quindi ho capito che le equazioni e
sofferenza uguale a sheena subito perché
il male il diavolo era sbagliata
[Musica]
non mi auguro in soffrire per carità
però se capita insomma non c'è stateci
ecco nella sofferenza
ho anche capito incredibilmente il
valore della preghiera a me la piccina
mi dicevano devi pregare gesù cristo
perché sono bello inferno e non capivo
non capivo e non capivo
adesso ho capito che c'è un dio dentro
di me e prego quello lo prego a mio modo
lo prego come raccoglimento
quindi ho imparato un nuovo concetto di
preghiera
[Musica]
siamo adesso mi sento libera
fondamentalmente mi sento molto libera e
mi sento soltanto dalla bilancia che da
una parte ci sono io libera e dall'altra
tutti i compromessi quindi mi sento
libera liberali ma anche di parlar male
ecco libera ed è una sensazione
meravigliosa libera di parlare anche
così anche se non potrebbe che ciò il
microfono qua sotto che mi non so mi sta
facendo molto male ma voglio essere
libera
tutto bello poi
rottura mi sono rotto una mano cambiamo
le lampadine pa rotta una mano mano
destra
cosa fa di lavoro del passo a scrive
perfetto ottima rottura glielo
felicissima felicissima ho detto cavolo
mi son rotto la mano destra parte
maschile finalmente posso venire fuori
da far venire fuori a mia parte
femminile e posso sviluppare la mia cate
vita
man dei giudei
ben
come lei sa today son day
cioè fatevi capitolo dovete farvi male
perché sennò qui se non si possono fare
cose che dovete farvi male insomma anche
perché quando io mi sono fatta male un
contratto nuovo che mi chiamano a luce
proprio come la causa delle lampadine
perché io giacosa delle lampadine mi
sono rotta la mano che mi faceva tutto
mi portava la colazione mi tratta bene
di chi a questo ma io mai successa sta
roba qui no no non lo voglio perché io
no io no io devo star male può soffrire
io solo quelli bastardi invece no un
contratto è lui l'uomo della vita anzi è
caro andrea sappi che questa è la mia
proposta creativa alla proposta di
matrimonio che tu devi fare a meno
quindi cortesemente mela d'oro apri
metti un anello
voglio dire non si può fare una proposta
di matrimonio a una creativa diversa
quindi grazie questa è la cosa
successiva un invito successivo a buy e
romanticismo ok quindi mi sento innovata
cellular mente e allora vi dico delle
cose quando vi dicono che ce la farete a
tutti i costi non credetegli non farcela
e da coraggiosi quando vi accusano di
perdere tempo perdete nel doppio perché
ne guadagnerete il triplo
quando qualcuno vuole farmi del bene
accettatelo anche se non siete avvezzi
alla ricezione
quando qualcuno mi dice tanto poi passa
rispondetegli che ora ora non poi quando
vi accade qualcosa di brutto state ce
non accantonata l'idea la potete
trasformare in bellezza
quando vi rendete conto di essere degli
automi che agiscono per frenesia
respirate
e ballate ama ballate per ghiaccio e
larga circa fuori a ballate
[Applauso]
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
poi chissà
[Applauso]
[Musica]